hey guys this is Pete peppers with candy
crush soda saga tips calm and I'm
playing level 295 to give you some tips
this is a really tough lob will probably
one of the toughest ones we've seen in a
while and I'm gonna play through until I
beat it and talk about some different
things to keep in mind now the pieces
always start the same so you want to pay
a little bit of attention to what I'm
doing here but they won't fall exactly
the same I this is actually I've played
this several times to make this and I'll
make that first move at the top where I
make the fish every time I think that's
the best first move but there's like
three or four different scenarios of how
the pieces will fall so I guess just in
general what I try to do is I try to hit
the jelly cake first and foremost
because I want to clear that out and if
I can't do that directly I look for ways
that I can move these I'm gonna here I'm
kind of stuck so I'll make one of the
bottoms or any things down but I try to
like clear out some of the honey at the
top above the jelly cake because that'll
make that'll help out later one of the
things that I want blow this up now one
of the things I noticed as you can see
I've made a couple fish here that can be
really helpful to have some fish sitting
around while you set off the jelly cake
because it'll hit those see how the
Bears have more damage on them already
but um you don't want to make waste too
many moves doing it you just sort of
want to do it as you're still planning
on hitting that and another thing is one
thing that I definitely noticed was is
you don't want to go out of your way
like it I don't know if you were paying
attention a couple moons ago I had a
over the on that side I had a chance to
make a color bomb it really wanted done
much and instead I set off the two fish
same thing here I mean I have a color
bomb and a wrapped but sending that fish
will get me into the next frame as fast
as I can and you can see that I have 27
moves which is just about what you need
I think in my first video I had like 25
or 26 anything beyond anything below
that I usually I'll usually just go
ahead and start over because it you need
every move you can get and what we're
gonna see this time is if by doing the
same thing like by hitting the cake and
by clearing out the honey at the top
that color bomb that we made is still up
there so it might drop down onto the
board later when we moved these last two
pieces of honey right here so that might
come in handy but even with 27 moves
coming in here there's definitely no
guarantee that you're gonna get finished
and you really need to plan everything
out at this point you're gonna need some
fish because the the honey is just too
thick on the inside row but again you
just don't want to spend too many moves
you don't want to waste anything I would
think most of the time on this board
like if you're really oh there's my
colored bone I think most the time on
this board if you're stuck and you can't
hit the jelly cake you probably want to
make a match towards the bottom because
that'll help you get some cascades to
come down so now we have a pretty good
set up we got by using our fish that we
had we got lucky and got rid of the one
at the top so now I think really the
only major problem we can have is
getting the one that's at the bottom
there's one bear at the bottom of the
corner who is I thought that was gonna
put the strength right by that for me oh
well this color foam is not I mean we're
gonna we're gonna try to use it
but it's not our main priority this
would be good because that's hopefully I
wanted that to go on the on the outer
room but anyways um we can let that
color well here I guess if we use the
color bomb on the yellow it'll free up a
lot of those bears in the middle oh we
only have six some who so I don't really
see anywhere where I can set up a combo
with it so I think that's probably gonna
be the best best plan see that's that
yellow one in there and then we get a
bunch of bears out okay so now this is
where it gets tricky we have one striped
at the bottom that's gonna hit that
layer of honey for us right now so yeah
there's that bear at the bottom that's
gonna be the hardest one I think I can
make this wrapped just because it's at
the bumping cuz I can't really do much
else I could match I green at the top to
get that one bear but I hopefully will
just hit that I guess I could do this
one now I think I yeah now I think I'll
make the raft because I maybe I could
hit these two together well that wasn't
very good set this one off that all up
them things up a little bit more we only
have one move left but we got our bottom
bear and now we just have to match this
green one and then Oh that'll get a
glass too for us so that's pretty much
how you do it it's um it's really tough
take your time I was playing a little
bit faster there because I was
frustrated I said I played a few times
before and didn't get very close so you
know hang in there some boards are gonna
be better than others there were some
people who were posting about like the
about how the pieces fell the same every
time I don't see any evidence of that
like I said that it is possible in my
video the first one if you watch you
know I got like a color bomb and a fish
early on and I've played that with the
same first couple moves and I get that
sometimes
but not not enough to say hey you know
just do this every single time instead
think about those things I told you and
keep trying if it gets if you get less
than likes if you get down to like 20
moves and you're still in the first room
just go ahead and restart to save
yourself some frustration and I hope you
get it soon I hope this helps I hope
you'll subscribe to the channel so
you'll get more videos like this and
like it and tell your friends and I'll
see you soon bye